le cema galibert dawei kissa magali
bertin alors non non bien sûr magali
bertin mais évidemment c'est qu' une
influence euse la reine des affluents
seul arrêt des influences dame a ravi
son interview les hommes politiques
regardez par exemple l'interview me
mélenchon cette semaine et pénales me
dire est ce que vous en pensez une
question très cash
vous détestez les riches
non non non peut-être que si vous
m'aviez rencontre et comme j'avais 20
ans oui je répondu oui j'aimerais quand
même je vais vous dire je connais des
gens pauvres odieux et des gens riches
très généreux je connais des gens riches
odieux et des pauvres régime
placés avant de vous lasser elle a reçu
très mûr avons regardé avec streit
zemmour on dit souvent que vous êtes
raciste des gens disent à beaucoup de
jeunes issus de l'immigration nous
suivent nous influenceurs vous avez
envie de leur dire quoi
j'ai envie de leur dire que c'est moi
qui leur proposent le plus beau cadeau
devenir français et s'assimiler à
l'histoire de 11 à la culture de la
france je leur dis à ces jeunes
regardez autour de vous vous êtes dans
le plus beau pays du monde avec un
peuple qui est sans doute le moins
raciste de la terre voilà elle se dit la
parole des gens qui ne votent pas des
jeunes qui comprend rien à la politique
elle a fait une chaîne youtube qui
marche déjà très bien aller vu ses
quatre ces cinq cent mille vu déjà pour
le pour le zemmour est ce que vous
trouvez ça ridicule ou est ce que vous
trouvez ça très bien je commencerai
zealand moi j'avais beaucoup
d'appréhension parce que je me dis le
monde de l'influent ça va être un gadget
etc et honnêtement je la connaissais pas
très bien je trouve que l'exercice se
laisse regarder 16h30 c'est une façon un
peu différente voire les hommes
politiques et je trouve que l'affairé
tient de le dire c'est qu'elle parle de
politique à des gamins et des gamines
qui n'en parle plus con même plus envie
de voir les hommes politiques oui mais
du coup c'est une chanson ce qu'on peut
lui objecter c'est que du coup c'est que
justement elle les gamins regardent mais
comme elle n'a pas la répartie et ben il
déroule un peu leur discours et du coup
bas les gamins entendre ce que je marque
à toutes les autres émissions qui
permettait de voir ces contre-pouvoirs
millar est intéressant c'est que sur 30
minutes sur des vidéos youtube qui sont
vu vos cinq cent mille pour la première
et là on doit être armé de passants
milles sur la deuxième donc ça va pas
non plus un impact faramineux ça reste
ludique elle et elle est naturelle je
trouve qu'elle est spontanée
seconde bonne idée mauvaise idée que je
veux un peu qu'ils pensent quoi ça parce
que je suis perdu alors tant que jeune a
juste eu la mauvaise idée pourquoi
mauvaise idée tant mieux si les jeunes
regardent c'est très beau pour les
intéressés mais en revanche on
s'improvise pas journaliste je trouve
que c'est elle s'adresse à les hommes
qui ont une rhétorique implacable et il
n'y a pas de contradiction en fait on
n'apprend rien dans ces vidéos elle les
suit il ya une question pour des moore
ils arrivent à y répondre hyper voilà
hyper bien et elle du coup elle
contredit pas c'est magnifique et les
journalistes a par contre je commençais
ça qu'ils font ça on l'a vu complètement
il est très humble elle dit moi je suis
pas journaliste je viens donner une
autre vision des politiques apparaît
alors bonjour il est nouveau c'est quoi
ton temps comment ne t'autorise pas
prendre la parole comme store ce
n'autorise pas pour la vie est très beau
et tu as compris mais j'aimerais un
deuxième nom et puis après bien sûr on
veut écouter que laurent oui bah comme
tout le monde côté possible chez s'y
intéressent les jeunes à la politique et
les poussent à voter c'est très bien que
pour quelques quel que soit le bord en
revanche souffre comme comme une
comédie comédie fiona c'est vrai qu'il
faut un peu de pâques grande en
politique et qu'on n'y connais rien mais
on est forcément on est passeur de plats
et les réponses
hippolyte là la première émission
c'était alex émond riccio alger que j'ai
regardé j'ai plus d'une minute trente au
bout 2030 elle dit il espère avoir ces
signatures voilà et sans signature je
rappelle qu'on a eu on n'est pas
remboursé non c'est pour se présenter
des effets certes c'est vrai je vois
c'est bon quand on n'a pas de culture
politique on dit des conneries c'est une
canine faisait pas tout encore guillaume
mais non mais parce que là on est dans
un gie un truc mais la raison qui l'a
mis dans be s'est
dit qu'elle était une journaliste
politique mais il voit là je suis mari
mais attendez elle a dit moi je suis
magali bertin et elle va poser les
questions elle n'a jamais voté enfin
vous connaissez magali verra lé tout en
plastique de la tête aux pieds
[Applaudissements]
elle en a pour 15 actions anciennes
écoutons ces coûts non mais ça n'a rien
à voir
mais attendez mais mais en bien j'aime
beaucoup magali berda et avant d'aller
voir eu un choc elle m'a appelé on en
est ce que tu as des questions à me
donner qu'est ce que je pourrais dire et
je lui ai dit il faut que tu dises ça
faut que tu dises ça elle dit mais c'est
pas mon rôle moi elle c'est un peu comme
confessions intimes c'est
fou le résultat c'est que on a un
assistant qui n'est pas très politique
qui connaît pas grand chose et du coup
il a regardé edit ah bah vous savez quoi
bein mélenchon il veut ça il veut ça
jamais il n'aurait ne se serait
intéressé à ça si ça touche même quatre
cinq six mois s'est passé encore
personne le but est atteint et le valais
d'autres et c'est vrai que notre
assistant a retenu que au delà de 38000
euros de revenus par mois et il allait
taxer 90% il est de retenue ni d'aidés a
déjà déjà et florian ton petit toujours
voilà très très bonne idée donc toi t'es
bonne série les voilà pourtant c'est une
très belle et je voudrais prendre à hugo
parce qu'il parle d' impact modéré enfin
j'ai entendu des choses un petit peu
revient pas que modérée j'ai clairement
dit voilà en fait non pourquoi parce que
depuis une semaine magali berda elle a
des papiers dans l'obs dans libé dans le
figaro on parle de on parle d'elle
partout en train d'être prises très au
sérieux par les politiques eux mêmes et
on recommence j'ai une anecdote à vous
raconte j'étais présent le fameux jour
où elle était entourée des influences
heuzé de marlène schiappa vous souvenez
on accorder saturn que le passé par les
dockers et par exemple en faisant
remarquer qu'un pas pour parler des
réseaux sociaux on pensait que ça serait
bien j'étais regarder ce qu'on a eu au
my god
bon les filles je vous emmène où la
jeune ministre
non match à part
il n'ya pas
alors pas content on respecte le
président d'arrêter dit voilà merci
manuel et manuellement oui on rigole
chez les baleines n'y a pas de débat
la
ministre
on termine florian j'explique parce que
j'étais autour de la table alors là on
ne vois pas je ne suis pas fait beaucoup
pourquoi l homme discret mais j'ai
assisté à une grande partie de la
réunion et toutes les influences euse
que vous voyez là qu'on a beaucoup moqué
sur les réseaux ou ailleurs elles ont
posé des questions très sérieuses elles
ont été vraiment elles ont vraiment joué
le jeu et sur leur réseau à elle sur des
sujets très sérieux de de violences
faites aux femmes etc elles ont vraiment
joué le jeu et magali à ce moment là il
est en contact avec marlène schiappa
depuis des mois avec elisabeth moreno
qu'est la secrétaire d'état à l'égalité
femmes hommes aussi et aujourd'hui elle
est vraiment prise au sérieux par ces
gens là ce jour là elle a parlé à marc
lynch à pale ale elle a soulevé l'idée
de faire un ministère des réseaux
sociaux alors au début ça a été un peu
ri avait demandé aussi à zemmour oui
mais la première fois c'était ce jour là
et c'est quelque chose qui est en train
de se discuter de plus en plus c'est moi
je vous parie que dans six mois
peut-être même avant magali berda aura
un rôle important attend juste des
braves gens mais c'est tout sauf une
matière magali oseo n'a jamais fixé
c'est tout sauf une idiote et on a
surtout tous les ministres qui passent
leur temps sur tik tok je fais si vous
avez vu surpris
j'ai marié le ministre a détruit sa vie
sur secteur ou entre magazine de vue non
c'est pour dire la politique non la
politique se modernise un peu et c'est
de se mettre au goût du jour c'est pas
seulement l'élite qui votent maintenant
les faisais trop élitiste demain il ya
des gens qui ne sont pas forcés non mais
ça n'avait eu à coeur du sujet c'est
quand même le programme malgré tout des
des candidats c'est ce que ma mère pour
la bulgarie le fait que max à la
personnalité des candidats soient
importantes et qu'on veuille savoir qui
se cache derrière un programme très bien
elle le montre mme magali mais faut pas
oublier que le coeur du programme c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour la france le
programme c'est ça le plus important
on a les
mérites et au pardon pourquoi la
politique serait réservé un entre soi
pourquoi est ce que les hommes
politiques vous serez reçu que par des
journalistes ils se connaissent avec qui
devenait trop les pousse à aller la voix
des sans-voix journée
alors je peux même pas jusqu'aux je
comprends pas pourquoi on l'asie secours
en élite et surtout vous qui êtes plutôt
d'une génération jeunes à voudriez tous
trouvé ça plutôt bien deuxièmement
attendait j'aime bien ces phrases qui
veulent pas dire grand-chose deborah
parlons je t'attaque direct mais ils
passent leur temps je connais très bien
de démarrer le ministre des transports
par où il passe pas son temps il fait
marcher les réseaux sociaux fait c'est
que tu attends c'est que nantes échos du
25 août il ya une fois par semaine mais
comme macron à vue a vu max annie
carlito et on montre généralement que
des images verture banques parce qu'on
al'impression exemple aïcha pas qu ils
ont tout fait elles ont toutes fait la
fête et qu'elles ont rien à [ __ ] de
rien ce que tu viens de très justement
les images qu'ils sortent c'est ça a
tendance à miner son chum et sous de
gaulle n'aurait pas fait des vidéos à la
queue leu leu
non je suis né aussi sous de gaulle
giscard d'estaing à fait d'accord
les ministres ou les présidents doivent
peut-être sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
est-ce que magali berda et les gens
vont retenir cette vidéo il faudra toute
la
colonie fiona et c'est bien ce qu'elle
fait ça c'est ça laurent la même chose
qu'on dit des otages en action mais
juste pourquoi parce que magali berdal à
près d'un million de followers sur
instagram et filles étaient autour de la
table parfois plus un petit peu moins
mais dans ces eaux là cela veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'elle parle à des
millions de gens assurent donc
politiquement et en vue d'une élection
c'est si
vous arrêtez change de débats bien pas
moi qui suis un peu rétrograde un peu
machin mais c'est moi de mon avis et ça
ne sera pas le débat ne sera plus un
autre notre mémoire macron qui fait ce
quiz squeeze et carlito ça m'a
passé par deux influents
faire botter les jeunes moi mais je
donne pas mon avis mais je les fais
juste moi le nom de apparemment de son
prochain invité sinon c'est ce qui
m'avait pécresse
abidal n'ont ils pas pour elle espère
alors appât macro 79 ou alors appât
macro 1 vous n'en savez rien
malheureusement vous n'en savez rien et
les clubs pas tous bien guérie elle
écoute choses et avancer c'est très
bonne du csc mais c'est une fille très
intelligente et maintenant elle son
petit défaut c'est que parfois la forme
n'est pas bonne et le fond est très bien
se montre e mail en examen les caches à
l'honneur